orangutans they can look into the future
and they have five hands but you won't
believe what they have in common with
your doctor
what's not cool about race Dance plus
raccoons their fingers act as eyes
they've lived in the White House
and they may just have the intelligence
to take over the world one day raccoons
kind of do have some superpowers
and find out which surprising Beast
bites much more than sharks
which dog is 50 times richer than
President Obama and which animal may
have the craziest sex drive in the
animal kingdom instead of fighting over
it and squabbling
they might uh partake in a little nookie
[Music]
where Savage meets science
wild becomes wow
this is everything you didn't know about
animals
[Music]
it has the strength of seven men and an
arm span bigger than Shaq
it can beat a man in a battle of wits
and in some countries he's given the
same rights as humans
[Music]
the only ape that's Orange
and in more ways than that it's in a
class all its own
it's the orangutan
[Music]
listen carefully
[Music]
it may not sound like much
but what this orangutan named Tilda is
doing is something scientists have never
observed in another ape
something they thought was impossible
for the first time ever this orangutan
is moving her lips to mimic human speech
scientific analysis has shown that Tilda
is delivering these strange sounds at a
rate seven times faster than any other
orangutan call ever recorded
and at a rhythm almost identical to
human speech
so our orangutans becoming more human
the word orangutan does mean people of
the forest to find out why we're looking
into all the amazing ways they may have
earned that name starting with this
these people of the forest may have
taught actual people how to make
medicine
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
it all starts with the orangutan's
ability to masterfully manipulate its
environment
one of the traditional ways that people
marked intelligence was through tool use
there was a period when we pronounced
that humans were the only species that
used tools and it turns out that is not
true either there are now hundreds of
species that make and use tools
where orangutans fit in that package is
right up at the top
they'll make ropes to swing from trees
hooks to pull things closer and they'll
even use leaves to make themselves
umbrellas or rain hats
it might not sound like much to us but
almost no other animal in the wild does
anything that even comes close
still these achievements May pale in
comparison to the orangutan's ability to
make and use medicine
like us orangutans get aches and pains
after A Hard Day's work but they can't
run out and grab a tube of Ben Gay so
some orangutans chew a plant known to
have anti-inflammatory properties into a
paste then rub it into their sore
muscles
it is the first known example of a great
ape using medicine in this way but
that's not all
local people have been making soothing
bombs out of the same leaves for years
and since the orangutans didn't learn it
from watching them it is believed that
ancestors of the indigenous people may
have learned it from watching the
oranges
unfortunately
orangutans are not in most people's hmos
firewire Carrot Top flame cranium
whatever you call them redheads make up
about two percent of the world's human
population
but what's rare for us keeps orangutans
alive because being the gingers of the
Jungle allows them to virtually vanish
Into Thin Air
thank you
you can play hide and seek with an
orangutan if you like but you're gonna
lose
[Music]
you can be following an orangutan and no
more than maybe two yards away and they
are in complete view you're looking
right at them and within a second they
vanish right in front of your eyes and
there's no sign and they are just plain
gone
it's a good skill to have
in a jungle full of orang eating tigers
but how can an orange sore thumb
disappear in a jungle of green it has
everything to do with how sunlight
penetrates the forest canopy
here's how it works as the light makes
its way down to the forest floor it
passes through vegetation which absorbs
red violet and orange light for
photosynthesis
by the time the sun's Rays hit any
orangutans below they've been robbed of
their oranges and reds
making the orangutans appear a dull
Brown
so when you see orangutans in the middle
of the forest they come out looking like
just a deadlock I personally have almost
tripped over orangutans you don't see
the Reds at all
slow
a lot of the time they are slow
but make no mistake orangutan brains are
moving a mile a minute According to some
studies they are the most intelligent of
all the non-human primates
smarter than our closest cousin the
chimp their brains are so Advanced they
can even see into the future
okay so they don't have a crystal ball
but their power of forethought May rival
any other animal alive
one of the ideas that we've had for a
long time about non-human species is
they live in the Here and Now
they can't see in advance so they're
pushed and pulled by the events that
happen to them right now well there's
fairly good evidence now on orangutans
that they can plan things up to a day or
so in advance I think they probably do
it longer than that
in that way they really can see into the
future and these forced people can use
that advanced thinking to outwit us real
people
take a look at this rare footage of a
human orangutan interaction
what you're seeing here is an adult
female orangutan her name is onyuk she's
watching one of the local field
assistants that works with the
orangutans using a new Swiss Army knife
to saw a small stick into short pieces
anyat watches fascinated
and even tries to imitate the field
worker using two sticks
you get the sense that you can see her
own puzzleman and her own working
through how to understand this unusual
thing that she's looking at
later the assistant tries to cut some of
anyuk's hair with the scissors
but the knife makes her nervous
until something changes
it looks like she's not interested
anymore
I was filming at the time and I remember
just being puzzled and it looked like
she wasn't there anymore she'd been so
engaged and all of a sudden she wasn't
Anya's gaze is now firmly fixed on
something behind the assistant something
she wants
his backpack
suddenly instead of being nervous of the
knife she actively solicits the
assistant to cut her hair
so she holds her arm out to him and
makes it easy for him and when he quits
she grabs the hair on her own head and
leads in to invite him to continue doing
it and then with the assistant
distracted
it happens
[Music]
grab and gets the backpacks
[Music]
so Anya saw something she wanted
formulated an advanced plan of how to
get it then manipulated the assistance
in order to achieve her goal
so for a species that you think of as
very slow not all the time
[Music]
of the four kinds of great apes in the
world today orangutans are the only ones
found outside of Africa but if you
believe some people these Asian Apes
have arranged much bigger than we
thought
can you guess which of these mythical
ape-like creatures some people think
could really be an ancient relative of
the orangutan is it a the yeti of the
Himalayas B Sasquatch of North America
or C the yowie man of Australia
plus find out how an orangutan's brain
is like a smartphone
[Music]
there is a Charming legend about how
orangutans were created
particular creation myth was that all
life on Earth was created by two
bird-like creatures
according to the myth they were
particularly pleased with how we came
out and they were so proud of themselves
that they had a big party afterwards
stayed up late at night celebrating the
party
the next day the birds tried to create
more humans
[Music]
fortunately they were kind of hungover
from the party the night before so they
made a mistake in the recipe and they
turned out orangutans instead
some Legacy
you could guess which mythological
ape-like creature some people believe is
actually an ancient relative of the
orangutan is it a the yeti of the
Himalayas
B Sasquatch of North America or C the
yowie man of Australia the answer all of
the above
you may not find a lot of people who
agree on whether or not any of these
beasts really exist
but among the Believers there are those
who think that all of these legendary
ape men
may actually be gigantopithecus Blackie
a thought to be extinct orangutan that
stood up to 10 feet tall and weighed
over one thousand pounds and that's
three times bigger than a gorilla
so is this giant orang still walking
Among Us pretending to be Bigfoot
they've earned the nickname people of
the forest but in some ways orangutans
May really be more than people because
while we can do so many things at one
time
they have five hands
unlike any other ape orangutans spend 90
to 95 of their time high up in the
Treetops
so to stay safe they need a lot of hands
to hold them up
first there are the actual hands strong
and nearly twice as long as our own
and then there are the orangutans feet
which can grip just like a hand they
actually can use their big toe to grab
so it's like having Four Hands
I kind of wish I had a Divergent big toe
kind of nice you know come in handy
but as it turns out four hands is still
not enough
in fact they have five hands because
they have their two hands and they're
two feet
but the most precise manipulator is
their mouth
their hands and their feet are occupied
holding them up in the trees so what
else are you going to use it's so
dexterous it can perfectly peel fruit
or even tie things in a knot in essence
a fifth hand
just think of the possibilities hey
catch
good
afternoon
if you're an orangutan getting food
isn't as simple as a quick drive to the
supermarket
for humans finding where to shop is as
easy as doing a search on our mobile
devices but it wasn't always that way
we used to be built like the forest
people of today with brains like a
smartphone
when you actually look very carefully at
what it takes to live the way they do
it's a huge job to manage to have a
balanced diet
so they have to have a shopping list of
in any month maybe 30 or 40 maybe even
50 different species of foods that they
feed on and they have to know where to
shop for every one of those
once an orangutan identifies a food
source it gets mentally geotagged so
they can keep coming back orangutans
they have kind of an internal GPS where
they actually can uh in their mind they
know exactly where to go to find these
fruiting trees and it's not just about
knowing where to find fruit and they
have to know something about the season
so it wouldn't make any sense for me to
go out and try and go and pick apples in
the middle of December I gotta know it's
September or August so they need the
same kind of knowledge
so stored in that smartphone of a brain
they also have a Farmer's Almanac
and it's even more difficult for them
than it is for us in North America
because their seasons are not as
predictable as ours are
[Music]
orangutans are one of the most
critically endangered Apes
as of early 2015 there were believed to
be just forty thousand remaining in the
wild down twenty thousand from the
previous decade
so maybe it would help if instead of
looking at how orangutans are more or
less like us we started looking at them
as equals believe it or not one country
already has
meet Sandra the world's first orangutan
with human rights
she was once a Mainstay at the Buenos
Aires Zoo
but in a 2014 Landmark ruling a judge
determined that Sandra was too smart to
be treated as an object
and was being unlawfully deprived of her
freedom
she was ordered released and is now
legally classified as a non-human person
I hope she's exercising her right to
vote and a party there's lots of great
wine in Mendoza I hope she's checking
that out all kidding aside this ruling
could have wide reaching implications
for captive Apes everywhere
thanks to Sandra one day we might be
calling these people of the forest just
people
a crow named Tata once lived to be 59
years old
during lean times Marina iguanas can
shrink their entire bodies bones and all
by 20 percent
the blue ring doxpress has enough Venom
in its golf ball-sized body
to kill 10 to 20 full-grown men
[Music]
the sexiest
more
wild party facts when we return
flamingos can only eat with their heads
upside down
a rat can last longer without water than
a camel
in New York people are bitten 10 times
more each year by other people
then by sharks worldwide
want to be the life of your next social
event just take a cue from nature
because whether it's the fact that
Penguins can drink salt water or that a
chameleon's tongue is as long as its
body there is a lot of wow in the wild
just waiting to be repeated
cheer now are our very favorite wild
party facts
according to one study almost one out of
five vervet monkeys in the Caribbean
prefer drinking alcohol to water
the Bohemian waxwing bird often gets so
intoxicated on fermented berries
that they fly into buildings
but for a more exotic High puffer fish
toxic is considered 40 000 times more
dangerous than meth 50 million times
more powerful than marijuana
just one dose can kill humans
some Dolphins gently chewing on the
puffer seems to produce a narcotic
effect
they've been observed passing around
pufferfish at their own versions of
parties
[Music]
for our next round of facts we go from
the biggest party animals
to the just plain biggest
oh
the biggest elephant ever recorded
weighed 24 000 pounds as much as two
T-Rexes
of course that's an exception
a lot of Asian elephants only weigh
around three tons
which is about as much as a blue whale's
tongue say ah
at six inches and smaller the tarsier is
the world's second tiniest primate
but in relation to its body it has the
biggest eyes of any mammal on earth
just one of its eyes is bigger than its
entire brain
a lot of people often refer to Tarsiers
as little aliens
they are just absolutely comical
[Music]
but it's not all fun and games in nature
warning things are about to get a little
bloody
[Music]
a 100 bat colony of vampire bats can
drink the equivalent blood of 25 cows
every year
a great white shark can detect blood in
the ocean
from up to three miles away
but the most gruesome of them all may
just be
the hairy frog aka the horror frog
when startled the horror frog will
actually break its own toe bones
then Pierce its own skin to create Claws
[Music]
and it's one of the only situations in
the animal world where it looks like an
animal intentionally breaks its limbs to
do something it needs to do
so remember no high-fiving a hairy frog
[Music]
no party would be complete without some
special guests of honor
so for this next round of party facts
we're getting fancy
in 2011 a rescued stray cat named
tommaso
inherited 13 million dollars when his
owner passed away
that's chump change compared to a German
Shepherd named Gunter
he earned the title of world's richest
animal
after inheriting 372 million dollars
from his owner
that's 367 million dollars more than the
estimated net worth of President Obama
finally it's time to send the young cubs
to bed because our last set of party
facts are for adult eyes only
Pros have no penis
koalas have two
when a pig makes whoopee it can last up
to 30 minutes
but the sexiest animal of all may just
be the bonobo
next is chimpanzees they are our closest
Cousins but unlike most of us they use
sex for everything from saying hello to
solving conflicts
cubanovas see a piece of fruit on the
ground or a Snickers bar and instead of
fighting over it and squabbling
they might uh partake in a little Nookie
and then maybe they'll forget there even
was a Snickers bar there bonobos are
also the only mammals besides humans
that prefer to face each other when
engaging in intercourse
but even for them the party has to end
sometime
primates like bonobos are one of the few
mammals besides humans that undergo
menopause
finally it's a fact all the parties you
attend from now on should be 100 more
Wild
especially if it's one of gunter's
parties that dog is awesome
[Music]
they can see in complete darkness
only their hands
[Music]
they've lived in the White House and
they could go higher than that
[Music]
could have raccoon astronauts they can
manage anything
plus you won't believe what they have in
common with Godzilla
raccoons are next
they've held court with the most
powerful men on Earth and made fools out
of Nazis they scaled tall objects by
changing the shape of their skeletons
and can feel an object before they touch
it
already among the craftiest animals out
there but we may be making them smarter
than anyone ever thought possible
all this and most people look at them
like pests
they are raccoons
in Washington DC alone there are at
least 90 raccoons per square mile
pretty much everywhere we are
they are too
I've been putting cameras out in my
friend's backyards to track raccoons in
the urban environment which is what you
do
um and my friends are always apologizing
in advance oh I'm so sorry I never see
any raccoons in my backyard and then I
put my camera up for one night and show
them the video
I've seen up to 50 raccoons go through a
yard in a nighttime
it's like a little raccoon highway back
there
so it's easy to see why so many people
view raccoons as common vermin
but we're taking a look at some of the
raccoon's finer points to see if they
really deserve their maligned status
and to figure that out we start by
asking what are raccoons anyway
they have ears like cats a dog-like nose
and the way they invade our space most
people think they're rodents
raccoons are not rodents I'm just gonna
say that straight out
I've heard people say rats bunnies
skunks
possums they are not any of those things
they are their own thing they are
raccoons they are a unique and wondrous
thing and they are not rodents I can't
stress that enough
what raccoons are is part of a family of
animals called procyanidi which includes
Coates kinkajus and newly discovered in
2013 olengitos welcome to the family
the third highest grossing film in North
America for 2014 was Guardians of the
Galaxy which featured a genetically
altered raccoon named rocket
he had finely tuned super sensus and the
intellect to be a master tactician
but how far off is that from raccoon
reality raccoons kind of do have some
superpowers lots of species are cool
like cheetahs can run fast and you know
elephants have those awesome trunks but
raccoons can actually become just about
any animal because they can adapt to any
situation that's thrown at them
in fact whether or not you think they're
pests
raccoons have the power to see with
their hands
oh
[Music]
touch would be their most super sense
that's how raccoons get around is they
they feel the world they see it by
feeling it
a full two-thirds of the part of their
brain responsible for sensory perception
is dedicated to their sense of touch
more than any other animal studied in
addition they have four to five times
more sensory cells in their hands than
most mammals
the nerve endings from their hands go
right to their brain and to a large part
of their brain
they can get an image of what an object
is without even looking at it so the
raccoons actually see with their hands
their Vision with their hands which is a
weird concept for humans is fantastic in
fact raccoons use roughly the same
proportion of their brain for touch that
humans use for sight
this superpower some people still look
at raccoons as super villains
especially Suburban homeowners with nice
lawns
but maybe instead of focusing on the bad
we should see it as another sign of the
raccoons incredible nature because they
actually have the power to hear a worm
breathing Underground
worms may feel protected in their
underground layers especially since they
can burrow up to six feet deep but is
that deep enough
it's a pretty good range of hearing but
raccoons have even better so we go up to
about 20 kilohertz and raccoons will go
up to like 50 or 60 kilohertz
so more than twice as high as we do
and that Hypersonic hearing allows them
to sense even the quietest sounds like
worms and grubs crawling underground the
thought that they could hear you know
worms and grubs moving around underneath
is pretty spectacular they have some
superpowers really
foreign
[Music]
the first written record of a raccoon
was penned by none other than
Christopher Columbus when he told the
world of his Discovery he described them
as a kind of dog we already know he was
wrong about that
but then no one outside of a small part
of the Americas had ever seen them
before
raccoons are native to North America and
Central America but not even all of
North America but sort of to the East
and the South now it's a much different
story there in all of continental U.S
and even Alaska the only place they're
not in the US is Hawaii
so they're definitely common but the
question Still Remains are they Vermin
and if so are they spreading
foreign
Legend has it that in 1934 future Nazi
party leader Hermann Goring allowed the
release of just a few raccoons into the
German Countryside
today they are nearly a million strong
and growing and are considered an
invasive species
but it's worse in Japan
before the 1970s they were almost
unheard of in the island nation
now they're everywhere
and causing big problems
[Music]
but how did they get to Japan in the
first place can you guess the surprising
way raccoons found their way to the Land
of the Rising Sun was it because of a a
shipwreck b a cartoon character or c a
prank gone wrong
[Music]
with their banded masks and striped
tails raccoons are cute whether or not
you think they're best but just how
powerful are those looks
President Calvin Coolidge and his wife
owned a pet raccoon during their time in
the White House they were actually given
a raccoon from constituents that was
initially meant like for the stupa
but they thought it was adorable enough
that they basically adopted it as a pet
and named it Rebecca
but then raccoons can carve out a place
for themselves anywhere
and that's become a big problem in Japan
before the break we asked you to guess
the surprising way in which raccoons
ended up in Japan was it because of a a
shipwreck b a cartoon character
or c a prank gone wrong
the answer is b a cartoon character you
can blame Disney for this one
in 1969 Disney released a movie called
Rascal about a boy with a pet raccoon
that story got turned into a 52-part
anime series in Japan and soon every kid
in the nation wanted their own Rascal at
the height of their popularity they were
importing something like 1500 raccoons
to Japan per year
problem is the anime series ended with
the main character releasing his raccoon
into the wild and then thousands of
Japanese children did the same
now raccoons are in 42 out of 47
Japanese prefectures
and by some estimates 80 of all ancient
temples in Japan have suffered some sort
of raccoon related damage the Japanese
government actually at some point banned
the importation of raccoons but it's too
late they're all over the place that's
because raccoons are so good at adapting
to whatever sort of environment in which
I found
for the people of Japan there's no
question raccoons or vermin but should
these animals be penalized for being
good at surviving
or should we be in awe of their ability
to bend their bones
just two inches about the size of a
pinky finger
that's all the space a raccoon needs to
make a break-in if you leave just a
crack like this big they can get in
when a raccoon stretches out its back
legs its spines straightens and the
raccoon's rib cage flexes allowing for a
lower profile even the big ones I've
seen them get through two inches and
they can get their rears down they just
put their legs out and they can just
slide right under but the power of their
bones doesn't stop at squeezing raccoons
can also rotate their back Paws a full
180 degrees
with their claws turned backward like
little grappling hooks they can climb
down most surfaces face first and ready
for action
Spider-Man's got nothing on the Raccoon
[Music]
so it seems like Vermin or not raccoons
are here to stay and if you believe most
scientists we better come to terms with
it because raccoons may be evolving into
a super smart new species
raccoon intelligence is long fascinated
scientists
in one study raccoons were presented
with 13 complex locks that involved a
series of steps to solve
the raccoons were able to open 10 of the
13 locks and were able to open some
locks in less than a second
and that's just your average raccoon
most researchers believe raccoons living
around people are becoming their own
super smart subspecies
I just finished a study looking at Urban
raccoons and their Country Cousins in
terms of problem-solving ability
I thought that the urban environment is
creating smarter raccoons so I wanted to
see if that was true
in the experiment Suzanne presented both
sets of raccoons with a trash can filled
with food
but secured with a bungee cord ended up
with 22 Urban raccoons and 22 country
raccoons
zero of the country raccoons ever
figured out the trash can with the
bungee cord
and 80 percent of the city ones did
even the little ones in the city could
figure out the trash can
it's a fluke
everywhere humans try to outsmart
raccoons
raccoons seem to be getting smarter
[Music]
I think what's happening is we have kind
of an evolutionary arms race between
humans and raccoons in the city so every
time we humans think we have outsmarted
them
the raccoons figure it out and then we
have to ratchet it up a little bit and
figure out something even trickier
and over generations of time you end up
with pretty smart animals at the end
[Music]
these amazing abilities should raccoons
be considered common vermin
Vermin possibly but common anything but
if we came back in 100 years I bet you
there'll be different species
I firmly believe that raccoons will be
our Overlord
fast enough to take a swipe at a
cheetah's tail
or pluck a bird from midair
it can jump onto the roofs of most
one-story homes in a single bound
its ears may be weapons and its teeth
can save sheep the caracal is next
the tiger is famous for those colorful
stripes
and the lion is the Undisputed King of
the beasts
but there is a much smaller Wildcat
every bit as impressive as its Marquee
cousins
it's only three feet long and 40 pounds
but it can run almost as fast as a
cheetah jump higher than a basketball
hoop and has been known to take down
more birds with one pounce than your
average house cat kills in six weeks
it's not a bobcat
it's not a lynx
it's the caracal
[Music]
thank you
Miracles are the coolest animal in the
world and they are just this amazing
Majestic cat that most people have never
heard of
but what is it that makes the caracal
the coolest cat you didn't know existed
[Music]
we're taking a look at just a few of the
most amazing reasons to care about the
caracal exhibit a it's got one of the
highest jumps in the animal kingdom
in a way caracals can fly
Birds beware not even the sky is safe
from the caracal
characters can leap at least 10 feet up
in the air there's anecdotal reports of
characters leaping as high as 15 maybe
even 16 feet into the air to retrieve
Birds that's high enough to slap a
giraffe on the chin
[Music]
and with powerful hind legs that are
longer than their forelegs caracals can
jump that high from a seated position
now you can just be sitting there and
then just spring up into the air 10 feet
and literally snatch a bird out of the
air
they're So Graceful and so powerful and
yeah you do feel bad for the birds but
they've got to eat
to find prey in the wild the Caracol
uses ears as sleek and complex as any
animals
so a human ear has about six muscles and
caracals have 20 muscles in each ear
that extra musculature allows caracals
to rotate each ear backward and forward
attentively of each other like little
satellite dishes collecting sound from
all directions
but a lot of animals have great hearing
the reason we may want to care just a
little more about the caracal's ears is
because they can use them as Weapons of
distraction
foreign
their main recognizable feature are
those long ear Tufts with these little
black tassels at the end of their ears
[Music]
a caracal's ear Tufts can be nearly two
inches long and while there are many
theories as to why they exist at all
they may all be part of the caracals
hunting strategy
I have personally observed caracals
slowly stocked towards their prey and
they'll flick each tassel
I'm not sure if it imitates the like
grass blowing or if you know somehow
that movement is just so unnatural that
you you look at that tassel as opposed
to looking at this huge cat stacking
towards you
so mesmerized birds don't see the rest
of the cat
until it's too late
just like the tiger
lion and every other cat
caracals are carnivores but for some
livestock ranchers that may actually be
a reason to care about the caracal
because they're killing can save lives
South Africa a battle is brewing
it's cats versus dogs but on a more
lethal scale caracals versus jackals
the caracal is outnumbered but not
outgunned but this cat doesn't run from
a fight
in fact caracals are so good at fighting
off jackals some sheep herders have
started intentionally releasing them
onto their land as protection
doing so one Rancher has gone from
losing 50 sheep a year to jackals
[Music]
just six
but for this caracal it's not about
saving sheep it's about survival
soon the outnumbered cat has one Jackal
on the ground and while the other two
try to counter-attack this artist of War
keeps them away
foreign
running
jumping killing caracals can do
everything big cats can do and more
it may just be the most amazing feline
you've never heard of
[Music]
[Music]